[Music]
and kittens for sale news submitted by
gangsta priests Claus praying you jumped
on it you're like that made me think of
daddy we're for digital cats have taken
over the blockchain industry in a rising
cryptocurrency frenzy
what the [ __ ] digital tab I just hear
they're called crypto kitty okay
I like real pets so what do they do well
real cats don't make you money unless
you make youtube videos out of them they
make the most money what he thought
doesn't fight anymore no no no I'm
talking like two hundred ether for one
crypto kitty is the current record where
do you get crypto kitties what the [ __ ]
okay so as of right now there are more
than 6,000 people trading an electronic
cat with the total transaction volume
exceeding seven million dollars as of
last week I am confused okay so um would
you like to create or would you like to
explain the whole blockchain thinking
I'm not all that okay so this is
actually a great way to explain
blockchain to people like it's it's it's
a really easy way for people to
understand it because it's basically
like imagine there's an infinite ledger
right that you cannot see what's a
ledger it's like a let go in your like
when you do your books like for banking
it's not like a counting ledger right
but you can only see it on the blocking
right like a digital record like it is a
record and so for crypto kitties and I
love it because it's very trolli to what
we all accept is economic norms
basically like there's only a certain
amount of crypto kitties that they're
generating like I think every five
minutes hmm
they're called generation zero or
something like that crypto kitties and
so then these are unique right they're
only generating this menace this like
beanie babies
generation 1 or it's like pokemon cards
right it's like this is generation 1
pokemon cards you're never gonna get
this again because we're gonna stop
printing them so it creates a
deflationary value to the crypto kitties
that are already in existence so the
people who are collecting them and all
that is is you're just sending it on the
blockchain and it's creating a different
version of the code that is uniquely it
right because that's what smart
contracts do that are that's different
then it's it's tough what exactly is a
crypto kitty it's just a little [ __ ]
picture of a kitty yeah it was like a
freaking some kind of Edward
Scissorhands cat what it looks like a
cartoon kid Tim a Tim Burton cat these
are so cute you really think that I'm
cute everything else what's stopping me
just screenshotting one of those
[ __ ] and going I got a crypto
certain traits and then they get to
breed them and create different kind of
kitties and why don't you do that with
Bitcoin you just Chris just screenshot
Bitcoin and then you can say you have a
Bitcoin right that's not how it works
for you to prove that you have this you
have to have a unique code that is
exactly that guys I'm saying that's
what's unique about smart contracts and
blocking is that like if you were to
send me like an aetherium right now yeah
that aetherium would be uniquely mine
now the code changes from yours to mine
yeah so there's like a there's like an
addendum to the code that is now
uniquely mine and what's cool about
smart contracts as opposed to a Bitcoin
the regular blockchain is that you can
kind of track where it came from so like
you can see like a supply chain of like
like like you say there was like the
salmonella contamination from a farm you
could track exactly where on the farm
this contamination came from so that you
don't have to throw away all the meat
from the farm right like that like they
do now they do mass recalls you just
have to like find this specific place
and then you can fix the supply chain
like it could really change the wall if
it's done properly or if it's utilized
properly and this is a stupid person's
way of understanding and I don't mean
that they're stupid I just mean it helps
people who don't understand blockchain
to kind of
their heads around it yeah because if
you send me a crypto kitty
it's now my crypto like I think you can
trade them right and then if you if you
breed them you need what's called gas
which is it basically allows you to
transact on the ethereum blockchain like
it lets you send gas is just the same
thing you put in your car it lets you
send like the idea behind it lets you
send aetherium to someone else mmm and
that's when it becomes I think bread or
whatever it's like a uniquely new cat
it's [ __ ] weird dude damn I mean it's
so complicated it's probably better that
they did something like this with the
kitty cats and all that stuff yeah
because I live right now at cerium is
the second most popular cryptocurrency
after Bitcoin and this crypto kitties is
the creation of axiom I don't know I
can't say that I know
okay well exams n and so they're the
ones that created crypto kitties and so
do kitty somebody make crypto titties
so I runs on the etherium platform and
so yeah this whole thing is getting
insane because there was one Kitty
that's sold for over one hundred and
seventeen thousand dollars Wow it was a
Saudi Arabian princess oh [ __ ]
and that just goes to show like why does
anything have value if somebody's
willing to pay for it that's what gives
it value right that's all that is yes
like for example there was this one
animal called kitten number 23 it first
went for more than $4,000 and then it
was sold two days later for more than 32
thousand dollars and in the following
day somebody paid sixty three thousand
dollars for it that's true because it's
like here's here's any old card right
but Mikey man will sign that card yeah
but Michael Jackson licked it right
exactly now it's a million dollars or
you get a piece of toast that looks like
Jesus Christ if somebody that's worth a
lot of money yeah period and they'll pay
for that that's why people like oh
Bitcoin they're ethereal also it's funny
money it's not real I'm like what's real
about your money right your money is
that they can touch it well right they
can touch it but what gives it its value
right that's what I'm saying like you
all agreed upon it that's the value
the trust but then if Trust is broken
then it's just paper no small value
right and like Venezuelan money right
now with this
unlike US dollars the Fed can't just go
print a bunch of crypto keys right
they're only printing a certain amount
of crypto kitties and then that's the
whole supply and so that gives all this
stuff of value if you're interested in
it and that's all it takes central power
away right yeah I didn't realize we're
just wiper them which is why I'm wary of
anything in the crypto world that is not
decentralized hmm like a lot of people
do tokenized economies and they keep it
centralized because they keep the lion's
share of the tokens so it's not
decentralized it's just a gimmick so
they could just pump it and do whatever
they want and then cash out on
everyone's and whatever they trade is
that yeah so they use everyone to drive
up the price and then they sell into it
and then it's over but then all of this
is yeah it's a cryptocurrency but it's
backed by what cash right um yeah well
they're they're it's really just uh like
like an aetherium right now is worth
like 700 bucks right so so that's like
if you were to if I was to like you
might not think cerium is valuable but
you think 700 ologist okay so that's
what that's what it's back back its back
for the current market price of whatever
aetherium is at or like how they value
gold and silver sure oh well then if
money goes down then all the crypto
grants you whatever
well no actually what's been happening
well because globally this is not just
like localized to the US dollars or what
our market is like globally Bitcoin has
value globally etherion has value the US
dollar goes down I mean Europeans or
whatever there's still the value still
yeah they're still bouncing bitcoins and
the etherium around it still has value
so it's very it's very unique to that
which is why Satoshi Nakamoto came up
with it or at least that's what we've
all heard that as to why because during
the banking crisis in 2008 yes exact
fulk that right he actually came in at
the perfect time with this and basically
said hey you want a different system
here's
here's how we start that I wish I was
smart yeah me too I don't even know who
is how do you guys have the name
they just haven't he went by him it's on
the white paper of when they created
Bitcoin is it was signed by Satoshi no
might as well it sounded Daffy Duck yeah
we don't know who is Daffy Duck is
changing the game I watched this
documentary on Netflix about Bitcoin
it's called banking on Bitcoin is it the
one with the Asian guy on the cover they
changed the cover on Netflix all the
time have you guys I've noticed that
you're like oh and you watch it I
already saw this [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so
so they keep changing that stuff but
they did that part on Satoshi Nakamoto
they thought that it was this guy in
NorCal with the same exact name he was a
programmer and he looks like eff Gemma's
dad and he's all that I don't even know
what this bitcoin is I have nothing to
do with it they kept it in the movie
yeah no they cuz cuz he was getting
harassed and in people were like they
wanted to have autograph or whatever and
then you see this old little Japanese
couple like going into the car like we
don't want to talk to the press and
they're just driving off and stuff I
pictured the couple from up yeah they're
like they're like the senior couple he's
an asian-looking version of that I mean
he's so totally they call his name is
Satoshi Nakamoto right no it was like
his Darian Satoshi Nakamoto or something
like that but what they're suspecting is
one of the members that were a part of
that the gaming Bitcoin team is like a
block away he lives a block away he's
thinking that he just took his name and
then he put it in there I dig pit
alright I wouldn't be pissed
like yeah I'll say new dhalsim whatever
you need me to sign that was me yeah
there's a lot of different theories on
who the founder of Bitcoin is but that
that was a pretty dope documentary yeah
it was great I liked it I mean it was
it's very basic but it's good if you
don't know anything about it so then if
I want to start making like crypto dogs
then can I just do that yeah go ahead
and program it learn solidity
super easy yep good great father give up
on your dreams good no I know yeah you
could feasibly
I mean that's what's cool about blocks
answers it really is yeah really
open-ended but also
the problem one of the problems with it
is you can just create it token like
right now I could create in the RC 20
token which is an ethereal base token
like it the trans acts on the etherium
blockchain
yeah I could create it on you have to
use this thing called meta mask anyway
to to to play with crypto kitties right
meta mask is just a browser tool that
lets you interact with the blockchain so
you can like put your aetherium there
and then you can pay with it basically
you know what you sound like to me right
now because this is all new vocabulary
for me you sound like one of those
homeless people that are just talking
about some crazy [ __ ] right yeah yeah
it's crazy cuz I'm like sitting here and
I'm like Dennis sounds [ __ ] crazy it
is it is crazy it's all it's all very
new trying to explain this to people has
been nuts but crypto kitties is actually
a really interesting way to introduce
someone to what smart contracts are hmm
so I support it and plus I love the
trollee nature of it like this whole
marketplace is worth 7 million right now
Blaire that's crazy
it's hilarious that's freaking crazy
there's no difference for that pokemon
cards they're still [ __ ] trading
that's true cuz those cards are freaking
expensive yeah there's I think the most
expensive one is like in the you know
another saying that the massive
popularity of crypto kitties is choking
the network and slowing down transaction
speeds so they're gonna trying to look
into making it better like to be able to
assist like all the all these people
trying to play crypto kitty it's making
a slow wedding by this time next year if
they're and will be so faster than gonna
have a problem cuz they're they're
working with this thing called plasma
that's gonna allow transactions to just
be [ __ ] like AZ I want to be rich
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]